spoiler alert no sue gray or met i'm
going to mention throughout the course
of this what i know can you believe it
let's start with the nhs backlog instead
uh your plan
well the the booking a treatment on an
app how does that work yeah so the
because of uh kobe the nhs rightly
focused on covert patients and it has
meant sadly that the the waiting list
has has risen significantly and i and i
have to tell you i think the waiting
list is going to continue to rise for a
while until it starts to fall and the
reason
we can't be sure and the reason is
because we estimate about eight to nine
million people stayed away from the nhs
because they were asked to they did the
right thing but we want them to come
back i want them all to come back
because i want them to know the nhs is
there it's open
for them but as they do of course that's
going to create more pressure and my job
the nhs job is to to get through that
elective backlog that coded backlog as
quickly as we can and what we're
announcing today is that part of that
plan will include a new online service
it's called my planned care and it will
mean that every individual on the
waiting list in england will be able to
see online exactly where they are on the
waiting list what the average weight is
in the area and other information about
how they can prepare for their treatment
the importance of this is that
understandably many people will be
anxious and stressful about their
position the weightiness is perfectly
understandable and we want to provide as
much transparency as possible of course
alongside this there's lots else going
on we're investing a record billions of
pounds in the nhs to get through that
covered backlog including investment for
example in things like the new community
diagnostic centers already they've done
some 400 000 extra diagnostics they'll
do an extra four and a half million by
2025 so there's a lot of investment
going in i just want to make sure that
we're doing everything we can to to help
people with their health and care no
matter where they live or who they are
and i thought for the families of those
that didn't make it because they were
waiting and sadly uh they've succumbed
to their illness well sadly of course
that that has happened i talked about
that
of course just on on friday when i
launched the a new
call for evidence for a new cancer plan
i went to a new 10-year cancer plan but
when i talked about that and just
preparing for that you know we we think
there's at least around 50 000 people
when it comes to cancer that sadly
didn't come forward they haven't come
forward uh because of covid and and in
some cases there's been devastating
consequences and a thought for the
families what would you say to them well
i think that
of course my heart goes out to anyone
that's been affected by that and their
families their their loved ones their
friends and i i would just want to
reassure people that inside government
working with our friends in the nhs
we're doing everything we can to get
services back up and running getting
them back to normal
unfortunately because of the omicron
variant which we've all now obviously
all know about just in the last few
weeks that's had another impact as well
but we're we're getting on with this and
we will also shortly be publishing a
very ambitious your full elective
recovery plan okay i was reading in my
telegraph newspaper this morning that
the plan is the nhs backlog plan is not
coming today because you've hit a
roadblock with the treasury
well it's not coming today because we
had a roadblock with omicron uh omicron
where i had actually planned to publish
the plan in in december and we were
almost there we're agreeing it finally
with the nhs and across government uh
but because of omicron we've rightly
changed our focus especially to boosters
and to to focus on that and
we obviously did the right thing it
makes us now the freest country in
europe and we're heading the other side
of overclock but we will publish the
plan shortly the reason i ask that is
because matthew taylor who you know who
is
the nhs confederation has said on
twitter increasingly getting the sense
that johnson now faces the same but more
intense and short-term challenge that
tony blair had in his third term we've
got this graphic i think normally hm
treasury is loathe to agree to any
number 10 plans involving money and the
chancellor so
yeah what do you think so they're
suggesting that it's the treasury that's
the problem oh in fact what i would say
about the treasury is that i couldn't
wish for a better partner when it comes
to the challenges that are this is wrong
i i don't recognize that at all because
actually i i can tell you personally
from you having been chancellor you know
having a close relationship with the
treasury having a strong partnership for
any department is crucial and right now
for health and care i'm just really
pleased we've got that really good
working relationship you talked about
the nhs backlog getting worse before it
gets better when is it going to get
better
it's hard to know because of the the
people that have stayed away it's it's
really hard to put a number on that and
we i've asked that question myself of
course of our friends in the nhs and
they will rightly well they rightly will
come back to me and say look a lot of it
depends on how many people come back you
know what's the of those people that
stayed away the eight to nine million
what proportion of them you know come
back to the nhs and as i said i can't be
clear i would like to say this if i
can't just make clear to your viewers
that if you're one of those people that
you know for whatever reason you you
weren't feeling well and you stayed away
from the nhs because you were told to
because you did the right thing during
the pandemic you'll please come forward
and the nhs is there but it will of
course mean that the nhs will will
have to
rightly deal with that find the the the
investments and and the procedures to
deal with that but the record amount
that we're putting in to the nhs that's
an extra 2 billion went in this year
just for elective procedures another 8
billion over the next three years that's
going to pay for something like an at
least an additional 9 million more scans
and tests and procedures and we'll be
able to you deal with many many more
people it's not going to be an extra 12
billion a year into the national health
and um and social care given that that's
how much the national insurance is yes
i'm just referring to the the money
that's ring fence for elective care of
course the nhs does does a lot more than
that okay um is the money that is from
the national insurance increase all of
that money is going to the nhs and
social care not going anywhere else
the levies all nhs and social care
forever
it's it's it was health and social care
it's broadly health and social care so
it includes for example spending on
vaccines but it won't be hived off
anywhere else it's it's it's a it's a
it's a health and social care so i heard
one of your colleagues at the weekend
saying for now
it's a health and social care levy the
the treasury's been very clear about
that okay um let's move on should we and
talk about um
jimmy savile
the row over jimmy savile has caused all
sorts of problems um the slur against uh
kia stammer in fact one member of the
downing street team
resigned as she says
as a direct result of that should the
prime minister apologize to the labour
leader well i i first of all i
understand the sensitivities around this
and this is why the the prime minister
himself after he said what he said in
parliament has clarified his remarks and
and really i think that's all there is
to this now in that you know i think we
should we just try to move on from this
there's so much else that is going on
and i think that we should draw a line
under this issue and just try to move on
because the prime minister has come
forward and clarified let's just say
let's just remind our viewers what he
actually said in the house of commons
this leader of the opposition a former
director of public prosecutions mr
speaker
he spent most of his time prosecuting
journalists and failing to prosecute
jimmy savile
outrageous
well i don't know if you've got the
other clip which was i think a couple of
days later where the prime minister did
clarify his remarks he clarified he
didn't apologize and it's just
it's it's it's it's important that he he
rightly set out what he meant it doesn't
it's not you know i wasn't i wasn't
there responding to
the report so it the prime minister has
said what he wanted to say and and
subsequently he's come forward and
clarified those remarks and this is what
rishi sunak said
can we listen to that
here we go being honest i wouldn't have
said it and i'm glad that the prime
minister clarified what he meant so he's
happy to say that he shouldn't have said
it he's also pleased the prime minister
clarified the remarks i don't know do
you want to play the clip of the prime
minister clarifying the rocks
have we got that can we play that please
i think you're fine it's my show all
right okay well it's interesting you're
not showing up what we have got is you
kirsten when he was running the the dpp
did a good job and he should be
respected for it it's a tough job and he
should just he deserves absolute respect
getting a bit testy about this why are
you so testy about it i'm not i'm just
saying that it's it of course it is a
sensitive issue i i get that and
that is why
these victims are furious that is why
the the prime minister rightly i think
it was just a couple of days later you
know made made it clear what he meant
and also what he didn't mean he came and
said that and that was right and and and
right now
you know hopefully you'll understand
your views on isn't this isn't the issue
that i'm focused on you know i'm not i'm
focused on my work at the department
which could not be more important we've
talked about we've talked about it quite
a
lot
we've talked about it quite a lot
but one member of staff who had been
loyal to the prime minister for 10 years
she stepped down because of the fact
that he wouldn't apologize even though
she told him to we heard what rishi
sunak said uh he says he wouldn't say it
you have said um as we illustrated there
as well that you know kirstama um has
your support why will this prime
minister not apologize when it's
blatantly obvious sometimes that he just
should
well look i i can't add anything more
than i've already said he's clarified
the remarks and i think that's really
it's the right thing to do and i think
hopefully we can draw a line under this
because he's been really clear about
what he meant and what he did not mean
and that and that i think was really
important okay would you have said it
it's not about me it's not it's not
about me no it's not it's you're in
front of me now i'm asking you would you
have said it no it's it's not about me
i'm not the one they're responding to to
the report you know i i'm responsible
for what i say and and i think i've been
very clear so mr sunak was wrong to say
what he said there but you have to get
mr sunak in and ask him well try every
week what can i tell you keep trying
yeah i will uh downing street has been
described as a dysfunctional and needing
a shake a shake-up dysfunctional and
needing a shake-up and how would you
describe dining street over the last two
years
um
well we've achieved as a as a government
and obviously downing street at the
heart of that a lot has been achieved i
mean downing street if you want to call
it that or government more broadly we
have uh you know just protected this
country from communism we've delivered
on brexit no was it dysfunctional no
it's not something i would have
recognized but one of my my own
work with downing street would have been
quite limited the but the changes that
are now being made is what the prime
minister he had promised this in
response to the update from gray where
sue grey herself i don't remember the
exact words in her in her recent report
but she had talked about the fragmented
relationship for example between the
cabinet office
she said a lot of stuff but in terms of
downing street she talked about the
fragmented relationship between the
cabinet office and downing street and
the need to make changes so i think the
changes that the prime minister has
announced in particular the appointment
of steve barclay you know a very strong
individual very good that is so it's not
but it's someone if someone means
nothing to my people but it is someone
who understands the cabinet office and
now having that link with downing street
now
i'm not going down that rabbit hole what
i am going to say is uh reports say the
prime minister has told his allies that
critics will need a tank division to
oust him from number 10. it's an honor
to serve it's not a birthright of course
it's an honest i want to serve as any
any minister well it doesn't just
because someone said that because i mean
you can hear him saying it
well i've never heard that so yeah this
is just some speculation
you shouldn't believe everything you
read in the press case i don't i don't i
don't also believe everything that
politicians tell me either
well moving on carrie johnson was your
special adviser when you were business
secretary you've seen the comments about
her in the book by lord ashcroft at the
weekend is this misogyny yes simple yes
it is it's sexist i mean it's
why
first of all i think the partners of
politicians should be off limits there's
no why would you go after attack the
partners of politicians by all means go
after the politicians but why their
wives their husbands or their their
partners because they encourage them to
break lockdown rules i suppose well no
this is uh this is not what this is
about this is just about going after an
individual i actually do think it's
there's a sexism involved in this that's
right i mean i really do i i do think
this and uh and i i would i just think
doing this you know going after in this
case you're going after carrie johnson
is it's undignified it's unfair and it's
just wrong this is her statement
actually she she's put out a statement
or on her behalf um here we go yet again
mrs johnson has been targeted by a
brutal briefing campaign against her by
enemies of her husband this is just the
latest attempt by bitter ex officials to
discredit her i suppose that's a
reference also to dominic cummings who's
apparently going to make more uh
revelations later on today she is a
private individual who plays no role in
government you would second that yes
what do you think jerry blair played a
role in government do you think do do
you think uh your normal major she
played a role in government i played
devil's advocacy because you know i have
no formal role in government and so this
is absolutely correct she was a
conservative party um she worked in
conservative party central office i
think previously so she she was she was
active within the party i'm trying to
play devil's i mean i i also don't she
she was as you say she was my special
adviser she was an excellent special
adviser but she's not in government in
any way uh he has no formal role in in
government and her
to the extent she would have any
anything to discuss with her husband to
do with government would be any
different from anyone before her so why
is she any different to anyone that came
before her as a partner of a prime
minister what would you say to lord
ashcroft and dominic cummings in the
light well i i i i would just say that
you know if you want to
you talk about number 10 these issues by
all means please do so but you know
focus on the prime minister
um
we all want to uh be successful in life
don't we we all have ambitions and goals
do you do you want to be
a leadership contender
you're going to tell me there's no
you're going to tell me there's no
vacancy
there's so many there and i've done that
and i'm just focused on my job i'm
really as you said it's an honor to be
in government in any role it's a it was
an honor for me when the prime minister
invited me to take on this job at the
time that he did in the middle of a
pandemic and
and that is it's a privilege every day i
wake up and think it's a privilege and i
do everything i can to help can you rule
out completely a leadership bid
i don't think there's going to be a
leadership election i really i don't i
don't think there's gonna be leadership
election because we've got a leader and
you really like your leadership we've
got a leader in place
that's doing a excellent job he's
getting on with the job he's delivering
on all the commitments that we made and
i'm there to support him alongside the
rest of the cabinet can you rely on a
leadership bid there's no leadership
election
it's good to talk to you thank you very
much for joining i told you i wouldn't
mention sue grey or the met
yeah chalk that one down thank you very
much it's great to talk to you thanks